welcome to this video playing Prince
panic Willie Hendricks move first think
later held at this book made some kind
of some I think I promoted his book a
little bit by the playing him and
mentioning mentioning his book all the
time so we have some I have wide against
the first of all that's quite quite rare
somehow i mostly got to God black and we
have some kind of um Italian game but
here it's a weird old Indian Indian kind
of kind of position how interesting
yeah I don't want to play Bishop d3 and
allow him to trade between each whatever
looks very very unnatural yeah so maybe
maybe he's not reading that I think it's
surprising I think you should be happy
to get some stuff traded but ok now I
can go a three before and push the night
back ultimately I think or is he going
for something else maybe for some f5
based business anyway not going to work
yet f5 taking f3 and Bishop g5 that
might be might be possible
whoa
hmm okay
kim a very interesting movie is g-form
let's do that it's very interesting I'm
weakening my dark squares like no
tomorrow but I've got space space space
lots of space and f4 I mean he has to
get there in the first place it's not
clear that he manages so with the night
amina to have form
you
yeah interesting night up to f6 maybe is
he going there
yeah I can also do it do that with the
king the open age file might be useful
for me at the end if you take that he
doesn't ok now nitey to 2 g-3 I guess
c5 is an interesting attempt in this
kind of structure to get some some
squares for the Knights but i think i
can take it on pass on and then night g3
should be good for one
they're okay
yep counterplay needs some kind of
counterplay c59 txt 5ss idea so take c5
now no not courage
just at g3 is also good let's do that
come on be a bit quicker here for once
hmm okay I didn't see that more coming
not at all okay
what about the age far there can i do
something on the edge farm I wonder
knight Knight to f5 next night 7 wait a
97-95 snot leading anywhere ok he wants
to get d 50 interesting Bishop g4 95
hmmm maybe 94 yeah let's let's do this
cheeks takes 95 night f4 that's all nice
and good but is it doing much maybe it
is
can also take here and go time morning
let's do that it's dead it's a kind of
show me move so I'm pretty advanced
there so if i get Queens traded and not
getting checkmated my pawns are strong
so I'm going for that
yes the trade right I can he can let me
take okay maybe but i also have queen
takes you five some upon seem very
dangerous there
yeah that should be good okay let's get
it go ahead him
not second-guessing here I need too much
time can be fatal and back here covering
c3 that's important 97 here maybe and
then then 95 just covering the porn for
night a 60 97 okay that's going to do
the trick check night Hanks that's the
point check checkmate yeah it was a
interesting game very interesting there
were a couple of capital of key moments
there 11 general thing I believe really
quite quite strongly he should take that
bishop because it should help him to
trade stuff because of his leg and space
I think that should help him allowing
bishops to I don't know I wouldn't have
done that it just keeps more pieces on
the board and we saw that later I'm
getting this pawn roller going and well
the night is just pushed back to a 6
later it's just more convenient to have
just one night as black so I think that
would have been an improvement yeah
that's a very funny funny move I
actually I actually had this one this
this and 22 that's interesting f6 yeah
that's his move Bishop e3 damn that
that's that's probably better for what
what is just better him that was better
right I thought that pushing the bishop
away then going before is interesting
yeah we went he went here queen of 16 /
voting age 5 that is some I can do this
now now that's not going to work yeah I
think why does a bit better here but
it's it's not it's not an easy position
to play g5 I don't know g5 fields fields
risky for white I don't I don't need to
do that just I think that here I'm just
keeping keeping a slight advantage yeah
the engine gives c5 that that's an
interesting move as i already said
during the game that that kind of thing
can be can be interesting this may be c5
that you have to get a night somewhere
somewhere in the game this can be
interesting I still a server
weird-looking bishop may be my age farm
maybe it's about equal to difficult to
say it's just a complicated position and
they overlooked some things here maybe
there wasn't something it wasn't
something fatal that I overlooked but he
surprised me with many moves here okay
engine is giving look aged one with what
exactly
not just keeping the whole thing okay
not playing c5 I don't want ended ideas
look h4 sometimes here could be a funny
idea but TM should check so engine gives
this move okay attacking the pawn that's
a good idea like this this and try to
enter who yeah many interesting ideas
but this I am not sure about that looks
very dangerous and I'm curious about
them comp assessments here because it is
probably relatively accurate the pawns
either promote or not yeah let's make
that's better right that he just played
that it looks a bit more a bit more
testing I appoint I'm very quick I'm
here yeah that's that we've you need to
test that but night f4 I mean I just go
to age one and then that's it check
yeah I think they're just too strong
they're just too strong but what can you
do yeah they were this was a very
unclear unclear middle game with with
many many chances that we'll probably
probably miss I'm ever to think we both
play that played decently according well
let's say I'm according taking into
account how tricky it was ok well thanks
for watching